the Oedipus complex is one of the
strangest and most counter-intuitive
Concepts in the whole of psychoanalysis
first formulated by Sigmund Freud in
1899 and taking its name from the
mythical Greek tragic hero Oedipus who
in eponymous play by Sophocles
unknowingly sleeps with his mother and
kills his father
this suggests that every child goes
through a phase normally between the
ages of three and five a physically
Desiring its opposite sex parent while
wishing to do away with or kill its
rivalrous same-sex parent
expressed bluntly like this the complex
tends to arouse immediate puzzlement
ridicule or disgust children aren't
generally to be witnessed expressing any
kind of sexual desire and we are
unlikely to remember anything in our own
lives remotely resembling what Freud
insistently describes as a universal
truth
however the explanatory power of the
Oedipus complex is likely to increase as
is often the case with Freud's ideas the
less literally we take it in other words
the more we view it as providing us with
an overall picture of the Genesis of
human sexuality rather than as a
concrete event in a given child's mind
we might think of the Oedipus complex as
offering us a guiding narrative about
how we come through the varied
experiences of childhood to have our own
distinctive approach to sexuality
the complex shines a light on a range of
questions how confident do we now feel
in our powers of attractiveness are we
disgusted or broadly at peace with our
sexuality do we think that other people
are likely to reject or accept our
advances and how much are we intimidated
by our desires
what is telling is that a huge range of
responses are to be found here some of
us labor under critical degrees of Shame
and Terror others have no particular
difficulty making our appetites known
and acting on them in reciprocal
situations sex may be a source of
exceptional Joy or the locus of
boundless masochism and paranoia
with Freud's ideas in mind rather than
imagining that we actually wanted to
sleep with anyone as children we might
say that we went through a phase of
exploring what it might mean to prove
attractive to a man or a woman
importantly we did so in the form of a
game one in which we no more wanted
things to become real than we would when
we played Pirates or jungle explorers in
the kitchen have wished to join an
actual Caribbean drug cartel or a trip
down the Amazon
little boys and girls will in a limited
way try out what happens if they attempt
to charm mum or dad at a given point
they might pull a highly endearing smile
and say they want to spend the rest of
their life with only one parent or send
the other one away or Muse that it might
be nice if they could have a little
wedding ceremony with one parent only
and here for better and For Worse the
games can unfold very differently
according to the emotional maturity of
the parent
in an optimal scenario when a small
child initiates a game the adult will be
exceptionally careful neither to shame
nor to excite them they won't say don't
be so silly or how repulsive they won't
get furious or punishing they will be
resolved enough about their own
sexuality not to take fright at its
first echoes in their child they will
notice What's Going On Smile indulgently
and go along with the game just long
enough for the child to feel
acknowledged and heard
and yet they will naturally not do
anything remotely seductive back they
will with great kindness ensure that the
game always stays very much a game
so much is however liable to go wrong
there are mothers and fathers too
fragile internally to allow a child to
flex their faculties of attraction
they get bitter or snide dismissive or
angry there can only be one Chief or one
queen bee
their appearance to deeply swallowed up
in cares and depression to allow
themselves to be Charmed and then there
are parents whose loneliness and
confusion means they mistake a child's
game for some form of genuine desire for
sexual contact with all the obvious
tragic lifelong repercussions that ensue
if we as adults have difficulties around
sex we might with Freud's edible Concept
in mind ask ourselves some of the
following
how much did I as a child feel able to
charm my mother or father
do they seem to take pleasure in my
existence with a angry sad or simply
always elsewhere
was my same-sex parent able to tolerate
my games or did they respond with
bitterness or bullying
concurrently how much did my parents
give me a sense that they knew
boundaries and would stop any game when
it needed to be stopped
Freud understood that adult mental
health depends on the early expressions
of our desire having been handled with
particular skill by those around us
without excessive punishment or license
without neglect or enticement without
anger or shame
the healthy adult is someone who can
feel potent without being terrified or
guilty their games went well and now
their reality can follow suit
Freud's edible complex becomes a source
of valuable Insight once we separate it
from its more literal formulations it
might show us why sex has ended up a lot
more complicated for us than it should
ever have been